John wig chapter 4 comes to the most
dramatic conclusion of the entire series
and it gives the titular characters a
much needed time off warning spoilers
ahead
as in all the previous films Keanu
Reeves iconic dog-loving Hitman racks up
an insane body counts throughout John
Wick chapter 4. however unlike the other
films John Wick doesn't come out of this
one alive John worked for all intents
and purposes actually dies at the end of
John Wick chapter 4. finally succumbing
to the many injuries he's earned
throughout the story the final blow to
work is dealt by blind assassin Kane
Wiccan Kane end up Dawning each other
with old antique guns Wick fights to
escape the high table's grasp and Kane
fights to save his daughter whose
survival is dependent on Kane killing
Wick luckily for Kane Wick discovers his
moral dilemma Rick also realizes that
his anger is only hurting those around
him and that killing isn't bringing the
feigned assassin any closer to Peace So
Wick decides not to shoot sacrificing
himself so that Kane's daughter can live
by doing so he also outsmarts the smoke
villain Marky Vincent degromand who
makes him duel in the first place
according to an interview at The
Hollywood Reporter director Chaz
tahelski says that bothi and Starkey on
Reeves are done for the moment we're
going to give John Wick a rest he goes
on to mention that the studio might have
other ideas but also seems to confirm
that the death is real and Final
John Wick's death at the end of John
Wick chapter 4 is extremely surprising
for a variety of reasons for one we've
seen him mow through other assassins
with ease as well as falling from Great
Heights so to see him finally succumb to
his injuries is jarring not to mention
that this means the main John Wick
franchise is over if the franchises to
continue it will need a reboot or a
major retcon to bring Jon back to the
land of the living the good news is
though that we still have the upcoming
spin-offs the continental and ballerina
both said in the John Wick Universe to
look forward to so beyond the shock of
the event itself what does this mean for
the long-running film franchise as a
whole well the death of the series
protagonist be a new trend going forward
arguably this will be a great Trend to
establish in a Hollywood landscape that
covers a constant continuation of
franchises and IP the end of chapter 4
lets stories and characters get real
closure there is even more precedent
including the death of Iron Man
signaling the end of the infinity Saga
and the recent death of James Bond at
the end of no time to die how hopefully
more franchises will take this approach
going forward
one thing that sets John Wick apart from
other violence R-rated action films of
the era Beyond this undeniable style and
Reeves committed physical performance is
this extensive and intricate law and
World building
John Wick
excommunicado the original John work
only scratched the surface of the
Assassin underworld but its subsequent
sequel significantly expanded on the
franchise's universe making it feel
lived in and consistent however with
Wick's death at the end of John Wick
chapter 4 the movie calls into question
what that means for the upcoming
announced spin-offs from John Wick this
is especially true for ballerina which
is set to Star Anna De Amos as the main
character with Len Wiseman directing for
one there's a [__] that has been
confirmed that Keanu Reeves filmed a
fight scene between him and the yamas's
character meaning it's either a prequel
or Wick's death was greatly exaggerated
furthermore if it is indeed a prequel
and Wick is definitely dead then it's
the movie setting up the armas as a new
face of the franchise unlike ballerina
which we know very little about at this
point the Continental is a show that
will stream on peacock about to get
Adventures of a young Winston played in
the original films by Ian McShane in the
new show he will be portrayed by young
actor Colin Woodall Rick's death
therefore doesn't seem to impact of this
Show's story still it'll be interesting
to see what the franchise looks like
going forward
at the beginning of chapter 4 John has
very few allies and even fewer friends
this is how Kane can catch up with John
Wick he knows that one of the few people
that would risk their lives to protect
WIC is the manager of the Osaka
Continental Hotel Koji it turns out to
be right as Wix seeks the help of Koji
and his beautiful and deadly daughter
Akira unfortunately working coaches for
Union is cut short by Kane's arrival
with an army of high table goons while
Kane doesn't want to fight either Koji
or Wick his daughter's life hangs in the
balance the bloody shootout leads to
Akira being shot forced to watch Kane
regretfully kill Koji as he attempts one
last time to protect Jon Kane however
senses Akira's injury and tells her not
to try to fight he has no intention of
hurting her he even saves will be
waiting for her revenge during the
post-credits sequence Akira makes her
move to take out Kane Winston for all
unlike John Wick who by the end let go
of the cycle of violence Kane instead
continues to perpetuate it and must now
face the consequences
in the John Wick series a high table is
the omnipresent infinitely wealthy head
of the Assassin World let me introduced
the world of John Wick in the first film
The intricate and strange rules that
govern this organization are background
details and fun but mostly disposable
World building a sequel however delve
much deeper into the lore a Mythos
behind those rules and rituals two rules
that cannot be broken Jonathan
no blood on Continental grounds and
every marker must be honored it
eventually becomes clear that the
Assassin world is completely dominated
by the high table the organization is so
powerful they can conjure up hundreds of
highly trained assassins at a moment's
notice to keep an eye on grip on their
subjects even John Wick had trouble
escaping their life and it eventually
catches up with him after his temporary
Escape it's also clear that the only
thing the high table cares about is
maintaining power they are willing to
threaten the children and loved ones of
Assassins to keep them in line as we see
happen to Kane however John wickster
finds the high table and its rules as
well as his continual success in
fighting off their attacks threatens the
entire underworld order at one point
Lawrence fishburns a Barry King declares
Viva La revolucion rebellious rally and
cry in support of John Wick's mission to
take down the high order's current head
the Marquis Vincent de gromand perhaps
work will even Inspire others to do the
same
there's something very liberating and
exciting about seeing John Wick a lone
solitary figure find a way to challenge
the longest Salvage power governing the
film sprawling underground assassin
world and in the film he inspires others
such as shimazu and Mr Nobody to work
against their superiors for the common
good in this case it helped fight back
against the powerful high table
organization however there's another
more cynical Take On The film's World
and the more probable conclusion of John
Wick chapter 4 after the credits roll
while the John Wick films are obviously
inspired by action films spy Thrillers
and crime Keepers they also arguably
have roots in film Noir this means that
there's a dark undercurrent to the John
Wick films and it isn't as gleefully
goofy as its superhero or fast and the
furious contemporaries Noir doesn't
usually have a happy ending and often
deals with the existential dread of
living in inescapable and corrupt
systems at the end of John Wick 4 while
Wick saves Kane's daughter and finds a
sense of relief and peace the world
itself doesn't seem to have changed much
Winston gets his hotel back the high
table still exists and assassins
continue to lurk in the shadows like in
the real world those who are powerful
enough will not only get away with
anything no matter how illegal or
corrupt but they will thrive the new Big
Bad of John Wick chapter 4's Marky
Vincent de gramonte played with
contentable arrogance by Bill Skarsgard
the Marquee has given unlimited
resources and card Blanche from the
organization to find and kill John Wick
and he sees this as an opportunity to
expand his already incredible power
however a main focal point of John Wick
chapter 4 and the John Wick Series in
general is how a corrupt system forces
people to do the unthinkable to survive
while those in power remain safe and
reap the benefits the Marquee is a
figure who can break rules and
traditions with impunity to get what he
wants he also doesn't do much actual
work himself when Wick challenges him to
a duel he cowardly passes off the job to
Kane instead he also has no ethics
morals or sense of justice as he
constantly changes the nature of the
deals he makes when eggs on his promises
and even physically harms his underlings
as they try to negotiate their contracts
considering our John Wick chapter 4 ends
coupled with the expansive nature of the
Assassin underworld it's likely that
spin-offs and prequels will be the way
forward however the size of peacock
Creek will show the continental and the
spin-off film ballerina nothing else has
been announced yet but what are some
other potentially entertaining spinos
from the John Wick universe that could
be produced one of the most obvious
ideas would be a young John Wick show
where we see Wick rise through the ranks
of the child orphan trained to be an
assassin this would probably mean no
reason since it's unlikely they would
attempt to use CG to de-aze the active
back to his Bill and Ted's Excellent
Adventure years
no way yes way Ted another idea would be
a spin-off show focusing on the newly
rebuilt Continental Hotel in New York
City it could possibly be a sort of
Anthology type show where Ian mcshane's
Winston acts as a host for guest
starring assassins and their
action-packed Adventures
as previously mentioned it seems pretty
clear that John Wick is dead and buried
at this point at least according to
direct dirt shots to helski it would
probably be for the best for the
character and franchise if Wick is
allowed to remain dead it provides
emotional catharsis for where because he
gets to go out on his own terms as a
hero and possibly reunite with his
beloved wife Helen in the afterlife
which is implied by the Snippets we see
of Harris as life slowly Fades away
however as the infinite supply of
sequels remakes and never-ending
superhero movies proves if there is
still an audience Hollywood will find a
way and while there are spin-offs
already in the works it seems likely
that studio executives are already
scrambling to find a way to bring Reeves
back to the franchise but how would that
be possible narratively speaking one
idea is that he and Winston work
together to fake his death using the
Bowery King as a reliable witness at
John's gravesite it could be a favor
from Winston to John for forgiving his
betrayal and giving him the Continental
Hotel back that might be what the
penultimate shot of Winston's tattoo is
all about Joe John is family and Winston
will protect him we didn't see his body
being buried after all